are you able to talk about some of the
scripts that you go through as examples
for part of the curriculum are you some
certain movies that you tend to focus on
or directors sure sure I use them I use
a lot of scripts because I'm encouraging
people to read I'm forcing them to read
as a matter of fact it's hard these days
by the way I must say even though I'm
Generation X I'm seeing myself being you
know torn away from reading more and
more how is that in this digital age
where you know 140 characters is
considered reading yes it's problematic
it's very problematic but you're getting
people used to the idea
just great yes and I with a greater
sense of personal urgency also if I may
throw a statistic at you in 1946 just
after World War two at a time when only
about 10% of the population nation's
population went to college or could
afford to go to college the GI Bill
hadn't kicked in yet you know it started
to change but in 1946 the America the
general American population had a
reading vocabulary of 25,000 words
that's not recognition that is used in
you know an everyday conversation a
reading vocabulary 25,000 words by 1990
the average American had a reading vocab
speaking excuse me speaking vocabulary
of 10,000 words and since then I am sure
it has declined precipitously since then
that is what happened you read less you
just see images you live through images
you you know you use emojis to express
emotion and you don't need words you
don't have the subtlety of words of the
variety of a vocabulary and it limits I
believe truly limits how people can
think even intelligent people how
completely they can think and that's why
reading actual words on actual paper is
incredibly important for young writers
and so you're encouraging them to read
novels as well or mostly just in the
screenplay format well I would say I
would hope I would hope novels as well I
mean that's one of the things I say look
guys if you were setting out to become a
novelist couldn't we take it for granted
that in your life you had read thousands
perhaps multiple thousands of novels
before you actually sit down to write
one
what should the difference be if you say
you want to be a screenwriter can't we
assume that you have written hundreds
upon written read hundreds of hundred on
hundreds of screenplays it seems to me
we can and then we do the hand thing you
know how many of you have read five
screenplays how many of 10 it tapers off
at about twenty twenty-five you know
there's no more hands going up and then
I slay up the task you must be reading
constantly you you cannot write what you
do not read you just cannot and so
that's one of the things one of the
hurdles we have to face and and draw
them into I mean they see if there's
these are smart people and they
recognize it bless their hearts but
that's one of the avenues where we have
to travel now yes I would encourage them
also to be writing novels I mean to be
reading novels because I think
ultimately they should also be writing
novels but that's just a separate
discussion but to to they don't have
enough time they're reading all the
other stuff for here and books about
screenwriting and filmmaking and and
then of course all the all the
screenplays Erin Brockovich is one of my
favorites Susannah grant screenplay for
Erin Brockovich I think that's one of
the better screenplays I've ever read
certainly in there you know with the
group there's so much to be learned in
that screenplay we were recently in one
of the classes they had have done that
and we spend an evening talking about it
the things that Susannah grant does to
make it work to give it a style a
narrative style as well as just
exposition as as it goes forward stuff
like that how she creates characters
that live and each one with their own
voice there's a lot to learn there a lot
but of course it's not the only one we
have bunch of scripts yeah but Erin
Brockovich just one of your favorites do
you think it's because there's also she
was a real person it's it's there it's
she's still around she's still doing her
thing and that's very active that's
right here on Twitter and yeah do you
think that that helps because it's a
it's a real person that they're basing
this story off of versus oh yeah yeah
most definitely in terms of you know
that single issue of character
absolutely the reason they made the
movie was because of the character and
what the character did but Tom Susannah
grant as a screenwriter was in a
difficult position there because I'm I'm
guessing I do not know for certain but I
am guessing that from the beginning when
they got the rights to Erin Brockovich
is story a MS Brockovich had in there
some sort of control over who the
screenwriter was going to be frequently
that's the way it's done so she
interviewed people and they kind of
clicked with she's clicked with Susannah
grant and Susannah grant probably spent
a lot of time with her getting to know
her hearing is hearing her speech
patterns hearing her use of vocabulary
and an emotional tempos and rhythms and
stuff like that
and so yes I would say absolutely it was
a powerful influence but that's only
where it began you know it's Susannah
Grant who picked the scenes and the
ordering of the scenes it's Susannah
grant who drove the story forward had
her character the main character driving
the story forward every step of the way
what she did with that was masterful and
there's something else about that one
too
love to burn love to burn up film here
tape there is a major problem in the
third act I mean this is getting pretty
esoteric but there's a there's a major
problem in the third act of
Erin Brockovich which there is a point a
dramaturgical point that must happen
must happen ends in films that are going
to connect with large audiences and
because of the circumstances this is a
Erin Brockovich is a courtroom drama
really it's about somebody suing
somebody so the big payoff moment what's
called the obligatory scene would happen
which should happen in a courtroom but
Erin Brockovich is not an attorney so if
it happened in a courtroom the entire
big moment would take place with Erin
Brockovich just sitting there silently
watching and Susannah grant recognized
this quite correctly so that this was a
dramatic big dramatic problem so like a
really good screenwriter does she found
a way around that that gave it the
emotional punch kept the focus on Erin
and gave it the the sense of victory and
emotion for the audience at the ending
instead of the courtroom we'd never go
to the courtroom do you remember
yeah I'm remembering certain scenes
right now definitely yeah yeah accord
the end she was running around getting
everybody to sign right up for it
because they had to X percent 90 percent
or something like that as all the people
in the town in had they had to sign this
affidavit or something like that and she
comes back and there's these two uptown
uppity lawyers and there's this funny
scene where she basically lays out that
she saved the day you know she's found
the smoking gun
she's got got the evidence and and it's
turned into a moment of emotional
victory for the hero with a substitute
adversary it's not timey they're not the
real adversary PG&E is the real
adversary right I know this is kind of a
subtle thing but it is a remarkable
piece of screenwriting to know that and
to write it in such a way that it works
plus she had been fighting that
stereotypical Uptown person throughout
her working with Albert Finney the looks
that she would get whether it was her
fault for the way she was dressed in
some of the comments but she was
fighting that same stereotype so it was
like a culmination of that at that
moment yeah they are a brilliant writers
substitute for to provide the emotion
that cannot endure these circumstances
because it's a courtroom drama and she's
not a lawyer but that can provide the
substitution of an emotional payoff for
an audience and it works it works how
does this Erin Brockovich grow how was
her character evolving and and changing
for the better in that film - trace -
trace character growth you have to the
writer doing it and anybody who wants to
understand it you know when it works
with other you know with other writers
doing it well in other films you have to
go back to certain basic questions and
the one in Erin Brockovich is what does
Erin want there is one thing and that's
what you have to get you know condense
it down to why she wants this she wants
happy kids she wants money she wants
what does Erin inside what does she want
and need and you boil that down that's
question number one this is good in
general kind of stuff when you're when
you're when you're writing a character a
lead character heroine er or hero right
you've got to know certain things about
what makes them tick I would offer that
what Erin Brock Erin Brokovich wants is
to be taken seriously everything she
does everything she says everything she
goes back to it is about being taken
seriously and but then she finds out as
she goes along in her story she's
getting closer and closer to actually
being taken seriously it's costing her
her family she's losing her children and
her children's connection to her because
she doesn't have any
for them anymore remember her son she's
really getting kind of twisted out of
shape and you know he's not happy with
mom at all because she's not around
anymore so the hero's journey
emotionally the inner journey it has to
be it always has to be hard that always
has to be difficult and you have to be
able to demonstrate it physically
visibly to demonstrate it and so you
have to know what they want and that has
to come out I mean really want their
primary defining want as a human being
right and you have to know they're wound
every character that works and every
character who has character growth
ultimately has this deep inner wound it
usually takes place in the past before
the film begins but not always
sometime in in Finding Nemo Merlin who
is the hero of that movie the wound
happens right at the beginning when he
loses his wife and 999 out of his
thousand eggs to this Barracuda or
whatever fish nasty fish eats them all
up and it's this is his tragedy but the
wound then defines that character for
the rest of the movie until they are
able to move beyond it the wound the
wound is when a person has a wound going
that deep even you know in reality let
alone you know it in fiction they tend
to insulate themselves and defend
themselves by creating this shield
between themselves in the world so
nothing that horrible or that painful
can ever happen to them again that's
usually when we meet them toward the
beginning of the story this person who
is isolated emotionally isolated behind
a shield and the journey toward
character growth is them figuring out
they have to get away from the shield
they have to lay down the shield and
face the potential hurt and pain in the
world in order to connect with humanity
and and lead a full life you know to
connect with earth again can people and
and really live a complete life rather
than just be caged up and you know and
be gone and and never have connected
with anybody else and that is what has
happened to Erin she is behind remember
you have the scene is still in act one I
think it is and she's got the tiara and
she's doing her speech because she was
Miss somebody he's Miss Wichita or
something like that right one some point
and and she said that I thought I was
gonna be somebody I thought I was gonna
be able to do something and then she
found out that she was just treated like
a dumb broad opening chain stores
department stores and they didn't expect
anything of her and they didn't want
anything of her they just wanted her to
stand there and look pretty and that was
her wound Shh she didn't see that I mean
she originally saw that as her
opportunity to Jew to break free and you
know be who she knew she could be but
didn't work so now in her life while
she's desperately trying to put food on
the table for her kids she is also
desperately seeking a way to get people
to take her seriously and that's a
wonderful place to start character
growth it really is and you see the
other co-workers and the different
people that she has to deal with and
probably one of the toughest
environments in terms of being accepted
in terms of she had lack you know no
education and sort of was seen again as
sort of a dumb whatever and and she's
coming against probably the worst
scrutiny and she feels it and she
strikes back and that's where we start
to see an interesting smart-mouth person
emergent yes exactly
do you think a lot of people related to
her care
okay heck yes that was an international
smash you know yes that's what I tell
the students - all the time
my approach to - screenwriting to
teaching screenwriting his mainstream
commercial Hollywood screenwriting
that's what I'm going for and that's I
give them the tools for that and there
are many many tools necessary really
that most of the people don't even
realize exist when they first come into
the program
but it sounds like her story arc was
relatable - yes yes is that is that not
universal
right isn't is her circumstance not
universally relatable sure to women all
over the world and then it was a hit and
it was a hit and many many men and it
was a hit all over the world and that
that's as some of the students are a bit
cynical about my lack of cynicism about
Hollywood and movies that make a great
deal of money but I I just point out
that what money means is this film
touched untold millions of people where
they live it gave them a some form of a
rewarding emotional experience they got
what they came for
a storytelling here is an instance of
storytelling it worked and that's what
we need to learn how to do because
that's a language that's a language and
a craft and a ritual that can be
mastered many of the students seen Erin
Brokovich yes I make them but most of
them and it's old enough movie it was
you know a short movie
yes and so people let's say that are
under 30 what's their reaction to the
film versus over 30 an interesting
interesting because it seems like
cynicism is in these days oh it is it's
it's you know that's and it's an its
effecting it's affecting the themes of
contemporary movies and spent hundreds
of millions of dollars making a movie
whose theme is life sucks and then you
die
mmm this is a very disturbing time yes
in Hollywood it is in many many ways and
that is comes out of the cynicism of the
young and this is true I don't know I'd
have a hard time saying that they all
read it and see it and they they are
they all speak well of it it wasn't
interesting either just the other night
we were talking about this one of the
students said she really didn't like
Erin Brockovich not the movie the person
I don't like that character she's an
awful human being and I said well you
know characters he leads who work in
movies they can't be perfect because we
don't like perfect people huh we want
her to know and love and care about
flawed people but and then you got a
list got a list the reasons we have been
given that the storyteller gave us to
allow us to identify with this hero the
Erin Brockovich and liked her anyway
even for her brashness and her outfits
and her outfits you know taste you know
no accounting for
you